I've got for you today the most
cringeworthy completely betta moment
that any American president in the sort
of modern era of audio-visual recording
has experienced Donald Trump was laughed
at not laughing with but very clearly
laughing at by the entire room of world
leaders at the United Nations General
Assembly yesterday Trump showed up and
he tried the stuff that he says at
rallies of supporters but instead he was
in a room full of world leaders and it
did not go over well what's the phrase
it went over like a lead balloon this
video is so embarrassing that I almost
I'm and the key word is almost I almost
feel bad for the guy but I don't okay
and what Donald Trump did in the video
I'm about to play for you is he tried to
claim that he has accomplished more in
his first two years as president of the
United States than any other
administration in American history
period which is quite a big claim right
you could say we're on track to do the
things I said I would do which of course
would also not be true or some way make
it a less bold statement
it's a ridiculous claim as he made it
and the room made him know that it was
ridiculous to the point of being
literally laughable settle in for this
prepare yourselves this is what it looks
like to be a total beta on the world
stage if you're allergic to cringe don't
watch this if there are kids in the room
get them out because this is really bad
let's take a look today I stand before
the United Nations General Assembly to
share the extraordinary progress we've
made in less than two years my
administration has accomplished more
than almost any administration in the
history of our country America's so true
didn't expect that reaction but that's
okay
yes III am like almost feeling slightly
bad for the guy but but I'm not and just
nobody in the room takes him seriously
he's an actual laughing stop stock he is
the literal laughing stock of the
world's leaders and he's talked before
about the United States and the
presidency being laughed at by the world
he was wrong he was talking about Obama
take a listen to this the world is
laughing at us folks they're laughing at
us at our stupidity they laugh at us
laughing at us it's just crazy what's
going on everybody's laughing at us
they're laughing at us
we don't know what we're doing think
we're stupid the whole world is laughing
at us laughing at this that's what's
going on in our country yeah the world
laughs at us folks the world laughs at
it's so funny because I don't remember
laughter at Barack Obama during the
eight years he was president I remember
some laughter with him because he was a
very good speaker and he was able to
very quickly build rapport with with the
audience but now they actually are
laughing at him the entire world is
laughing at Trump world leaders are
laughing at Trump I was just all over
Europe spoke to people in so many
different countries in Europe they are
laughing and scared everywhere and it's
all fun and games and Trump's a [ __ ]
but this is actually more than that
because it's not just Trump it's also
people around him right apparently no
one explained to Trump the dynamics of
speaking at the UN nobody thought maybe
we don't want to put this up on the
teleprompter because when Trump said I
didn't expect that reaction it was
actually like a genuine honest moment
from Trump he really had no idea that
that's how a roomful of world leaders
would react to such a dumb hyperbolic
and unbelievable claim to just laugh at
the absurdity of it and there's a really
interesting other sort of psychological
question which is how is Trump going to
rationalize this after the fact
I saw UN ambassador to the UN nikki
Haley on Fox News I don't even want to
play it for you because it's so so
unbearable but she said something like
oh no they were laughing with him and
they were laughing at the thing he said
after the thing and everybody respected
him and everything I don't even want to
play that people
because it's so dumb I mean that
response would make sense if he was
cracking a joke when you laugh with
someone but that was a serious statement
that he made he was completely serious
and more than likely Trump will say that
people were laughing with him or it was
sort of a brothers-in-arms situation we
all say this stuff we get you good one
Trump he might go on a tirade against
the entire room although it's less
likely in this case because it is the
leaders of basically every every country
around the world this is actually
finally the recognition and reception
that Trump deserves right Trump all
along has deserved to be laughed at by a
roomful of world leaders and he's up
there acting like it's another
presidential rally and expecting I guess
that kind of reaction and all of a
sudden wait a second they're not
clapping they're not cheering they're
laughing at me
yeah you can tell that he's not used to
it I mean his supporters they love the
guy so they're not gonna laugh at him
folks like us folks like you know media
personnel we're all just kind of used to
it we're so desensitized you and we
understand the seriousness of the things
that he says so we're not laughing
either but people like the world leaders
at the UN they don't see the guy too too
often so they're in a position to laugh
they're actually shocked that someone's
showing up and saying this stuff and I
don't want to only focus on the laughing
because Trump's entire speech made no
sense he said positive things about Kim
jong-un he said nothing at all about
Russia he mentioned China in a very
strange and offhanded way and is now
talking about Chinese interference in
American elections still without
mentioning Russian interference he
insisted globalism was bad while clearly
not even understanding what it means
made some thinly veiled attacks on the
United Nations itself and then he
complained about how other countries
aren't giving us money and that was
probably the most surreal moment of the
speech other than the laughingstock
moment where he said we give poor
countries so much money they give us
nothing which makes sense because
they're poor and that's exactly what I
want to talk about next here